and we are going to begin this hour with
some big news from NASA plans to return
to the Moon even though the mission's
two years away the space agency is
ramping up preparations and the Artemis
3 mission set for 2025 which will send
the next man and first woman to the
lunar surface well today NASA and Axiom
space they are unveiling the design the
spacesuit that will be worn by these
future Moon Walkers and first on CBS
mornings Mark Strassman traveled to
Houston to get a sneak peek of the new
suit
it's got to be one of the most proud
moments of my life I guarantee you
spacesuits to go back to the Moon NASA's
closet needed a refresh that is the most
beautiful sight in space to dress for
success is a matter of survival how hard
is this
uh very it is it is very very
challenging the glove bladders is kind
of the inner layer Russell Ralston works
for Axiom space last September NASA
hired the Houston Aerospace company to
build a new spacesuit for the first
Artemis moon landing mission to the
lunar South Pole here shadowed craters
are home to some of the coldest
temperatures in the solar system almost
400 degrees below zero going into a
permanently shaded region on the moon is
it's something that's never been done
before
uh by anything
NASA spent 15 years developing its own
Next Generation Moon suit before
Outsourcing the project to Axiom the
company adapted more than half of NASA's
design so this is it it yes it's pretty
close inevitably we'll tweak a couple
things but in large part that that's
that's pretty much the suit with one
notable cosmetic difference the color
the outer layer will be white made of
mylar and Kevlar so the actual flight
suit will look more more like this what
about this suit would make kneel and
Buzz and the the Apollo guys jealous oh
probably everything I think this suit is
going to have a a huge leap forward in
terms of Mobility
[Music]
suits were bulky inflexible moonwalking
astronauts often fell getting back up
look like slapstick it was hard work
yeah Charlie Duke was the 10th man to
walk on the moon
he remembers even the simplest of tasks
like picking up a hammer was a struggle
working against that suit was demanding
squeezing the gloves and moving the arms
and trying to bend over and so it was
exhausting
[Applause]
foreign this suit will be much easier to
walk in or to do the to do a lot of the
same tasks that they did back in Apollo
and more but to do it in a little bit
easier way
Axiom engineer Russell Kelly slipped
into the suit
to show us how flexible it can be you do
that pretty easily
oh yeah it's a
it's not too bad it's a top to bottom
redesign the helmet's greater visibility
and These Boots Were Made for
moonwalking thermally insulated for the
moon's South Pole can you hit a golf
ball in the suit I hope so I think you
can and until now no spacesuit was ever
designed to fit a woman oh I think it
looks really cool Peggy Whitson is
director of human space flight at Axiom
I'm heading back to the pool the former
NASA astronaut has spent more time in
space than any American and completed 10
spacewalks wearing suits now more than
four decades old and some of them I
couldn't even get my hands together that
makes it hard to do a lot of detailed
and delicate tasks just to have a suit
that fits oh it's huge
this 21st century spacesuit is made with
21st century technology laser cutters
precisely slice different Fabrics
these 3D printers build components
saving time and money but some parts are
still assembled the old-fashioned way
an axiom's sewing room we met Zach paw
his resume includes the Houston Ballet
and Cirque du Soleil his new challenge
space gloves there is definitely an
added sense of responsibility with space
work this is more exacting this is more
exacting yeah exactly
axiom's suit prototypes will eventually
be tested here at NASA's neutral
buoyancy laboratory part of the 40-foot
deep pool now simulates a South Pole
lunar landscape we can mimic partial
gravity NASA's Laura Kearney oversees
the program and will make sure Axiom is
meeting requirements it's going to give
us a really great indication of how
mobile the suit is and again what kind
of fatigue if anything the crew members
are going to feel after working for six
or seven hours
making a suit for an astronaut is no
ordinary trip to a tailor and Axiom
knows the stakes I go to church with
astronauts we see them when we're
getting groceries we we know their kids
the product you're making their life is
going to depend on that so it's
something we take extremely seriously
the moon seems closer than ever and this
new suit is a big step
for CBS mornings Mark Strassman in
Houston
oh amazing I just want to know like how
do they seal all those seams in the suit
because they have to be airtight right
but if you saw him they're making those
stitches so it in any guesses just very
carefully I guess I don't know probably
many many many layers yes yes I love
that blooper reel from the Moon oh poor
guys falling over I know oh my gosh if
these new suits are going to be a game
changer yeah yeah I like you like the
colorful gloves it's kind of unfortunate
they're going to cover them with the
white gloves like you know maybe for the
Halloween costume version we can get the
colorful kind and for women I'm thinking
they have breastplates right something
that gives gives a little more room for
women yeah upper I'm sure they're taking
it all yes
what are you trying to get at Michelle
I'm gonna take this